[Music]
in military disrespect Muse oh what the
hell oh she's so soft its soft thoughts
okay that's why I didn't hurt guys is so
soft
that's like you skinned a muppet alive I
don't know my Grover dude you [ __ ]
killed Grover Super Grover is the blue
one yeah you skin girl that's right
Super Grover hmm a teacher and I Oh
submitted by oh now he did no no he gets
[Music]
are just so graceful bro
it's like a [ __ ] Chinese so [ __ ]
soap opera I'm just like snatching a
piece of thread off with somebody's
[ __ ] t-shirt a teacher is under fire
after telling his class that the
military are comprised of the country's
lowest of the low I've heard this that's
like that's I've heard that a lot
multiple times too and not saying that
it's true but a lot of my friends who
went to the military yeah or some big
scumbags I would say like the way that
the military is set up majority are
probably not the brightest but then you
also have the very very elite class like
people that go to Annapolis West Point
whatever and those guys that part the
military is pretty much like becoming a
senator or becoming a governor and
you're like getting into military
politics and they're fighting war at a
different level and you have like
Special Forces guys so it's it's you
can't really put up link it statement
out like that because there's such a
huge crazy range like you have some of
what you have Wall Street brokers that
are probably like economics majors that
are super bright becoming a Navy SEAL
and then you also have like the dumb
[ __ ] from McAllen Texas like that you
have pawns and then you have
nights and the castles yeah you have
your higher-ups and then you have the
the except for Jake case the other way
around it's the two retards are on top
[Laughter]
teacher and even within this military
there's like a kind of a spectrum to
like a lot of the smart guys go to the
Air Force you know I just have its own
branding tune that's right
yeah so this man here he's a high school
teacher and a councilman in Pico Rivera
oh man come on
yeah here man I like a Pico and I'd pick
with the guy we got that 24-hour Walmart
yeah oh yeah yes that's where the lowest
of the low go mm-hmm
so maybe just representing his yeah
that's why they recruit he's speaking
from his experience perhaps the army
recruiter's this out of context it was
it was a false statement I will show you
a video oh comments it's chopped up cuz
there was like three videos and yeah so
he was apparently set off by a student
wearing a Marines sweater one and so his
father those students fathers a veteran
and so he this student secretly recorded
this teacher going off and saying you
better freaking it you better not
freaking go like to the military and
then I'll play the audio for you guys
here this is the teacher and we can't
freakin control these dudes where you
bring in rows and chocolates
[Music]
don't feel like you got beat up by
military people or something like got
picked on or bullied
Razia [ __ ] you were saying some racist
[ __ ] do ya
robes and chanclas yeah what the fun of
it nummies throwing rice at you because
they're fighting for us that's what you
think yeah who becomes a teacher that is
Horace KD there's a lot of good teachers
out there now was it a diss on teachers
I can't believe you like this guy can't
believe he's teaching to you or he needs
a councilmember he needs to get me be
rejected for your military
and you get rejected from the military
means you pro suck really bad yeah yeah
so this teachers name is Gregory Salcido
come on bro you got absolutely delicious
you know the military is like great for
helping people that are you know from
poor incomes like rise up and learn no
you learn discipline you learn structure
you learn you know you get schooling and
all that stuff and then the GI Bill
helps you get out of that and you can
get housing you get so much so like I
think a lot of people who are poor they
use the military as a way to like rise
up in the world and he's he's coming
from a very ignorant and small-minded
perspective because he it sounds like he
clearly doesn't know about that whole
structure you know what I mean like
where you have your higher ups and he
doesn't even know the incomes of the
people that are like I'm a thousand
million percent sure he doesn't know a
single person that serves in the
military like who does it without burn
but yeah I'm pretty sure he doesn't know
cuz he wouldn't be saying that well he's
a better bitter bitter bad also feel
like you could make that argument about
anything that you wanted to like exactly
because that's why I said like who
becomes a teacher because not that I
think that but like you could make that
argument like Oh teachers those who
can't do teach remember that say it's
like like people could go off on a rant
about that or you could be like who
becomes a priest who does you know you
could say that about almost any
profession yeah this is sad cuz it's
like he's a minority right and he's like
influen influencing so many young minds
and at such a crucial phase because it's
in high school and instead of uplifting
because he knows the struggle that like
Latinos go through you know and instead
of telling them like hey you can do this
but don't end up in this run or anything
you put your mind to whatever he's like
tearing them down like it's like a power
trip he like legitimately compared
having military recruiters to like
people pimps and hoes like that's some
crazy comparison you're like you're an
educator look it doesn't make any sense
man he also said this it wasn't included
in the audio here he said how come when
you go to like the Rose Bowl Rose Parade
Dodger opening day why after the
national anthem do we have a killing
machine flying over the freakin Stadium
you know the stealth bombers out there
and everyone's like yeah that's what we
kill people with like why would why
would that be something we celebrate I
don't get it anyway you better not
freaking go he's so stupid does he
understand that's why it's like we live
the way we live yeah yeah that's what a
lot of people are saying like you know
we have this green on because of people
fighting for us every single day out
there like how can we protecting our
country those are the show plane was
crazy this is the crazy he's crazy I
hope he what happened to him young he
was placed on leave and so at the time
when this video certain cuz the person
that uploaded this video was the aunt
was the aunt of the kid that recorded it
and so apparently at this time at the
time when this went up the teacher was
in New York vacationing with family and
then by the time you got back he said
that he's received vulgar and violent
threats and so he does not want to
comment at all like it with the media so
he scarred yeah I feel like he also got
a place he was placed on the leave from
the from the Council he said yourself
involved in yeah I feel like this guy is
just not intelligent and he just can't
tactfully explain how he feels because
he probably has some legitimate angers
and concerns but he's not expressing it
right so people don't want to listen
because there are things that I I don't
like about the military I don't I don't
have anything against the people in the
military I'm like thank you for your
service right but I'm I'm against how
the military is used I'm against how
like politicians use it for profit
yeah and and and that [ __ ] is wack but
it's a necessary evil like because there
are other bad people out there or other
nations that are power-hungry and in the
forces of power like who would you
rather be in the winning team or the
losing team I rather be in a winning
team
but it sucks because it's like ah do we
have to exploit others to stay number
one I don't know that that really sucks
yeah but that's a better than our
argument to like to express than to say
like your [ __ ] that you want to [ __ ]
go out there and be in [ __ ] lowlife
like because I've had family members say
it like that - and it's in it clearly
because this family member it clearly
comes from a place where they don't know
that there's like different tiers and
levels and job positions like your
family members against the military say
something to that effect and not that
disrespectful we got your plans II
usually people who on the military it's
because you ran out of plan a through
why I'm not gonna do didn't go to plan Z
but that usually that comes from a place
of ignorance because you don't know that
you can enter at a very low level you
can enter at a medium level and in
almost every like general and above has
like a PhD because you have to go to a
lot of school to get to become a general
like they don't know that there's a very
high level of military - yeah yes
they're mentioning that he has
historically been a very popular teacher
with the students that the students
describe him as real inspiring and love
because he he said [ __ ] all the time
like he just you know yeah when I first
went to college and I heard my
professors cuss I was like oh my god
this is so cool and when I look back I'm
like they were kind of stupid yeah like
they try to be cool like they were the
geeks or whatever to the students no
that's all a student commented saying
that he's a teacher who cares greatly
about his student success but
deliberately provokes debates in his
classes and encourages his students to
have a deep conversation that's not
debate that's not debate he's not using
the big words
yeah it sounded like a one-sided race oh
right yeah yeah and then sometimes he
has very sorry a very sarcastic sense of
humor and sometimes and maybe taking the
wrong way is what the students well
maybe I'm not in his class yeah you know
it could have progressed there like
maybe day one was syllabus day and he
didn't act out that way yeah but maybe
you know throughout the semester you get
to know him and then he explodes like
that all on a regular
yeah because the student who recorded
this because a lot of people were saying
like how that's hooked up at the student
record without the teacher even knowing
but the student was just saying that he
just got tired of him constantly bashing
the military all the time at this point
like he went into class with the Marine
shirt or sweater and he was just like
I'm just tired of this and so he
recorded it and he was showing it to his
family he doesn't even sound like a
professor slash educator like no do you
think less what subject does he teach
geometry like something completely
unrelated yeah like a PE teacher I get
our school if you were to coach a
athletic team you had to also teach a
class yeah so a lot of the history
teachers were like just baseball coaches
or like oh no yeah I coaches the city we
just literally read from the book yeah
George Washington had some [ __ ]
wooden teeth or some shape you guys and
you guys figure it out yeah I haven't
came across what subject he teaches so
I'm not sure anger management
[Laughter]
tragic bro that makes me so sad it's
funny when people try to like yell their
way into your brain it's like you
immediately shut shut down when anyone
tries to convince you anything in this
matter
yeah he's like what there's a comment
that says that he's supposed to be
teaching history so I don't know how
yeah I never called it yeah it seems
like that's a football coach yeah that
has to do history I don't know for
usually the coaches like the military -
yeah
[Music]
[Music]